LSD stands for lysergic acid
diethylamide, a chemical derived
from fungus.
This is not the psychedelic that
they're thinking about or that
they're having fun with.
The kind of power washes you from
the inside.
Something that does approximate a
natural religious experience.
You're colonizing it, they're
damaging us. You're embracing our
cultures.
A gruesome spectacle of how drugs
can ruin a brilliant mind.
That does Iive a life of pleasure
and joy.
There are a lot of people out there
who just want to explore their own
consciousness, want to have mystical
experiences, and we feel like they
should be able to do that.
Everywhere around us, there are
signs of a psychedelic renaissance
in medicine, therapy,
commerce and the arts.
These drugs are getting serious,
positive coverage in glossy
magazines, best selling books,
literary memoirs, documentaries
and hit podcasts.
I wanted to know what this was like,
and so I arranged a series
of guided
trips.
Ayahuasca is usually described
as a grandmother spirit and
I met
her.
Performers like Reggie Watts,
Melissa Etheridge and the members
of The Flaming Lips openly
acknowledged the role of
hallucinogens in their work.
I was 16.
I experienced LSD for the first
time. So much came into perspective.
I think the discussion
of psychedelics
and plant medicine
is extremely important.
And a flourishing psychedelic comedy
scene is springing up all over
the place.
Ketamine is like if someone
just like, threw you out of an
airplane but gave you a tranquilizer
for.
I guess I'm toppling around through
the atmosphere.
Nearly every country
in the world, including the United
States, is a signatory
to an international law banning
the use, sale, cultivation
and possession of dangerous drugs
that have no useful place in
medicine.
But federal prohibition of
psychedelics, a term that refers
to a broad category of consciousness
and perception altering substances,
is also changing.
The Food and Drug Administration is
expected to approve therapy using
psilocybin, the psychoactive
ingredient in magic mushrooms
and MDMA, the drug
also known as Ecstasy.
And Molly.
Oregon and Colorado, have already
decriminalized the recreational
use of plant based psychedelics.
Word is that even the president,
famous as a teetotaler for
having an addict son and
as a major force behind the
half-century long drug war
is very open minded about
medicinal use of psychedelics.
The most recent pulsing Day-Glo
sign that the psychedelic
renaissance is here took place in
Denver in late June at the
Psychedelic Science 2023
conference, organized and hosted
by the Multidisciplinary Association
for Psychedelic Studies or
MAPS.
This is about humans helping humans.
Founded in the late eighties, MAPS
has spent decades working to get FDA
approval for MDMA- assisted
therapy for PTSD and related
conditions.
At the conference, a reported 13,000
people gathered to talk about
what seem like every possible topic
related to the productive use of
these substances.
According to MAPS founder Rick
Doblin, this is not the far
out radical reordering of society
envisioned by Timothy Leary, the
Harvard psychology lecturer turned
psychedelic evangelist.
We look at what happened in the
sixties, and a lot of the
things that came about from the
psychedelics were
frightening to the culture.
Stand still.
Reality. Man.
Reality.
I could see the center of the earth.
In pursuit of mainstream acceptance
and to gain the approval of federal
regulators and establishment
figures.
MAPS is emphasizing the medical
benefits of psychedelics over
their potential to bring spiritual
enlightenment and societal
transformation.
Large pharmaceutical companies have
entered the field, putting much
needed capital into research.
But they've also stirred controversy
by attempting to patent compounds
that the grass roots say shouldn't
be commercialized because they
belong to everyone, especially
indigenous communities that use them
first.
But the biggest takeaway from the
MAPS conference is that there's no
inherent conflict between the
science and spirituality of
psychedelics, and that a former
Republican governor, a current
Democratic governor, religious
seekers, tech-bros and
unapologetic recreational users
can be allies in pursuit of the same
goal.
This event may be remembered as the
beginning of a new psychedelic
renaissance with immense potential
to radically change therapy,
medicine, work, art
and community.
Message. It's very simple.
Six words.
Turn on.
Tune in.
Drop out.